[Applause]
please be seated
good morning my name is Peter Owen and I
am the proud dean of the school of
general studies welcome to the class day
ceremony celebrating the accomplishments
of the general study 70th anniversary
class of 2017
yes I'm especially pleased that
President Lee Bollinger Provost John
cotesworth executive vice president
David Madigan Dean of Columbia College
James Valentini and University chaplain
Jenelle Davis are here to share in our
celebration
in addition we are honored to have with
us today professor Cornelia vole Provost
of the Institut d'études politiques de
Partie known more commonly as gospel
Cheon PO is the leading European
University specializing in the Social
Sciences we are also honored to welcome
vice president Horace hip and his
colleagues from the City University of
Hong Kong and a warm welcome to mr.
Thomas mish low emits an clean plug Anna
from the French Embassy in Washington
they and their colleagues have joined us
this morning to celebrate the graduation
of students in our dual be a program
with gospel and our joint da program
with the City University of Hong Kong
all of these students have earned two
bachelor's degrees in four years one
from Xian PO or CDU and one from
Columbia I would like to extend a
special welcome to our class day speaker
miss Julia Batra Gia's class of 2003
finally welcome to members of the
Executive Board of the GS Alumni
Association the creation of GES seventy
years ago
represents a milestone in the evolution
of undergraduate education at Ivy League
universities there are two major factors
that make GS unique first we actively
recruit students who have taken an
untraditional path and mainstream them
fully into a traditional and rigorous
undergraduate program second we are the
incubator for innovative dual and
jointly a programs that offer students a
unique opportunity to engage with
cutting-edge international education our
flagship joint program with lift College
of the Jewish Theological Seminary was
established over sixty years ago twenty
five joint program students will
graduate this week we are especially
pleased that 61 students will be
graduating from our dual be a program
with cells Po and eleven students from
our joint VA program with the City
University of Hong Kong
the
the present in the classroom both
traditional and untraditional students
enhances significantly the quality of
the intellectual discourse among
students and faculty and makes the
Columbia undergraduate experience unlike
that at any other Ivy League university
there's absolutely no doubt that the
success of gs is due to the commitment
of the Columbia faculty to our mission
and our students at GES you will find
over four hundred and sixty veterans of
the US military
102 of whom will be graduating this week
the largest cohort of vet US veterans
[Music]
the largest cohort of US veterans to
graduate from Columbia since World War
two no other Ivy League
no other Ivy League or selected private
university comes even close to that
number we are without doubt the gold
standard for undergraduate veterans
education in the United States whether
GS students are veterans dancers
entrepreneurs firefighters or
professional chefs like chef Jacques de
that class of 1970 who will be receiving
an honorary degree at Wednesday's
commencement ceremony whether our
students are Wall Street bankers or tech
innovators whether they are working
parents professional models or survivors
of medical or personal traumas whether
they are international students or new
Americans they received the same superb
education as all other Columbia
graduates and they excel
members of the class of 2017
you represent the cutting edge of
American and international undergraduate
education and you have proven yourself
through your academic accomplishments
and your dedication to one another and
Columbia we are privileged to count you
lifelong members of the Columbia
intellectual and alumni communities
[Applause]
since he assumed the presidency of
Columbia in 2002 Lee Bollinger has
articulated a dynamic vision for the
future of this great University in the
past 15 years president Bollinger has
spearheaded Columbia's expansion into
Manhattanville in West Harlem the
breadth of president Bollinger x'
intellectual vision is exemplified in
the first two buildings that have
recently opened in Manhattan ville the
Jerome L green mind brain behavior
Science Center which will house the
Zuckerman Institute and the lens fest
Center for the Arts president Bollinger
has also moved Columbia into the
forefront of international universities
with the establishment of Columbia
global centers in nine major cities
around the world
most recently he announced the creation
of a new institution embedded in the
university called Columbia world
projects in describing this effort
president Bollinger writes what
universities have not yet done is create
institutions that aim across a broad
range of specific topics to connect
academic work and the broad capacities
of the academic community
with organizations and parties beyond
the Academy that possessed the power and
influence to transform all this into
concrete consequences benefiting
humanity this is the purpose of Columbia
world projects Lee Bollinger is also a
committed educator continuing to teach
an undergraduate course on the First
Amendment even while he leads this great
university it is my privilege to
introduce the 19th president of Columbia
University Lee C Bollinger
[Applause]
thank you Peter I want to extend my
warmest congratulations to you the class
of 2017 and to your parents and families
and friends and since I will be speaking
to you at the University commencement
ceremony on Wednesday I want to be
extremely brief this morning there are
really only two things that I want and
need to say the first is about you and
general studies it is common to refer to
general studies as the place within the
university that affords access to people
of uncommon talent who have led lives
that depart to some extent from the norm
and so we refer to you often as
non-traditional students I can't tell
you how deeply proud I am of general
studies and of you and your predecessors
it is as Peter said Peter said unique in
higher education in America and it
recognizes that brilliance flourishes in
different ways and at different times in
human lives you represent the best of
that belief I have found in life
I have found in life that it is often
the case but the ways we are
characterized by others as we make our
life choices continues to define how we
actually think about ourselves you may
or may not think of yourself as a
non-traditional student but I would
recommend that you consider it a very
very positive description and keep it in
mind as you continue on with your lives
when you face a hard or important
decision in the years ahead as you no
doubt will it may be helpful to frame
your answer in terms of what a person
leading a non-traditional life would
choose - often I'm afraid we move
through life more or less as we are told
or expected to do you therefore are very
fortunate to already be viewed as
individuals who are not in the standard
mold in my view that is something to
treasure the second thing
the second and last thing I want to
raise is your Dean Peter on
[Applause]
so we're going to do this twice this is
Peter's last graduation ceremony as dean
of general studies for two decades he
has led but more importantly created
this extraordinary institution
personally I can testify to his having
had profound influence on the
development of General Studies and the
university truly profound but what
defines Peter as Dean is his utter
devotion his love really of you the
students of General Studies I urge you
to let him know in every way you might
think of how grateful you are it will
mean the world to him congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations and I'll see you on
Wednesday thank you Thank You Li and
thank you to my fellow graduates of the
class of 2017 our class day speaker this
morning is the distinguished documentary
filmmaker and writer Julie Abacha Gia's
class of 2003 originally from Brazil
Julia came to New York to study English
eventually matriculating @gs where she
pursued a degree in Middle East history
Julia graduated in 2003 magna laude
Phi Beta Kappa and as a member of the GF
Honor Society Julia has used documentary
film and multimedia to foster
constructive worldwide conversations on
some of the most divisive issues of our
times especially the israeli-palestinian
conflict
she began her filmmaking career in Cairo
where she wrote and edited control for
which she was nominated to the Writers
Guild of America Award in Jerusalem she
co-directed in counterpoint which won
Best Documentary prize at the San
Francisco Film Festival
she then directed produced and wrote the
screenplay for boudreaux's which was
awarded the Ridenhour documentary film
prize she most recently directed and
produced my neighborhood which won a
Peabody Award she is currently working
on a Sundance supported film for which
she received a 2015 Guggenheim
Fellowship
in addition to over 20 Film Festival
Awards Judea is the recipient of the
king hussein leadership prize search for
common ground award and the puma created
impact award she is a member of the
Council on Foreign Relations a young
global leader at the World Economic
Forum and a regular TED speaker Julie
lives in Manhattan with her husband
Lucas well and their two amazing
children at commencement on Wednesday
Julie Abacha will be awarded the 2017
University medal for excellence the
medal for excellence is awarded to an
alumna or alumnus from any school of the
University who is under 45 years of age
and who possesses an outstanding record
in scholarship public service and/or
professional life
please join me in congratulating Giulia
bata on her award and welcome her as our
class day speaker
[Applause]
Wow Thank You president Bollinger Dean
on Provost cotesworth
members of the faculty and
administration proud parents and family
members to thrilled and terrified
graduating class of 2017
congratulations it's incredibly humbling
to be here with you today it's been 14
years since my own graduation and I owe
so much to this school it's safe to say
that my professional and personal life
would look completely different if the
school of general studies did not exist
I was born and raised in Rio de Janeiro
but as you some Brazilians out there and
when I was 17 I came to New York to
learn how to speak English for one year
before returning to Brazil to the law
school in which I was enrolled for
contacts in Brazil law school is an
undergraduate degree when Brazilian kids
are 16 they have to decide if they're
going to become lawyers actresses
doctors or engineers there's no four
years of liberal arts education so while
I was taking English classes here in
this campus I had a wonderful professor
Shelley Saltzman who one day seen how
enthusiastic I was about the history
classes I was auditing on campus at the
time she looked at me and said why don't
you apply to study here and I thought it
was a crazy idea I was just beginning to
be able to follow a big academic book in
English and I didn't have any of the
standardized tests that were generally
required but I was in love with the idea
of a liberal arts education I wanted to
explore I wanted to learn philosophy
astronomy calculus and Persian before I
decided
what I would do for a living and so
thanks to the incredible support of the
faculty and professors at GF and beyond
on this campus as well as my parents and
my step parents I was able to fulfill my
dream about two years into my studies at
GF two planes flew into the World Trade
Center towers killing thousands of
people my mother called from Rio or Jami
to go back to Brazil but it was too late
New York was already my new home and I
became determined to understand why that
had happened and what we could do to
avoid more suffering in the future
those questions were still very much
inside me in 2003 when I said were you
all sitting there today it was going to
be a few months before my first trip to
the Middle East that trip set in motion
my career as a filmmaker a career that
has until now been exclusively focused
on that region of the world in a way
I've spent the past 14 years searching
for answers to September 11 I
unfortunately don't have the answers but
I have come to understand one key
component to a saner world and that has
to do with the power of your individual
attention it's possible that much of
what I'm going to say might sound simple
perhaps even painfully obvious but like
many of the most obvious things in life
it can be easy to take them for granted
and forget at key moments the profound
consequences that they carry and I'm
afraid that's exactly what we've been
doing
to great harm to ourselves so what's so
profound about attention first of all we
all seek it at any point in time during
competition for your individual
attention every year billions of dollars
are spent by multinational companies
social causes and new apps all seeking
to capture it it's been that way for a
very long time but the Internet age has
made the attention economy dramatically
more competitive and has highlighted how
directly our attention can impact the
shape the world is taking around us in
English we say pay attention incline
we're recognizing that attention is a
currency valuable and finite but what we
sometimes fail to remember is that this
currency is one of the most powerful
forces shaping the world today how does
that work I'll start with a small
example my son kite he will be two years
old in a couple of months for me one of
the hardest parts of parenting has been
trying to reinforce his good behavior by
showering him with attention when he's
happy giggly and warm unfortunately
that's no easy task I work full-time and
we have two kids in addition to KY my
husband and I also have a four year old
daughter named Neela time is precious so
when KY is content and playing quietly I
try to squeeze in something that I've
been meaning to do like playing a bill
or cleaning the dishes or putting away
the toys not exactly
reinforcing his good behavior but when
he's cranky there's nothing more that I
want than to have him stop whining so I
will drop anything and pay attention to
him and their childhood psychologist
will tell you life's a great danger you
are teaching your child that can terms
our successful ways to capture mommy's
attention now the same theme the same
thing happens with us adults
we've come to embrace tantrums as
functional behavior in fact if we look
closely
we'll see how entire communities and
countries are constantly learning the
most efficient ways to get the world's
attention as a society the most direct
way to observe what we are collectively
paying attention to is through media
coverage what's on the front page of the
New York Times today what's on CNN
tonight what's trending on Twitter right
now what was on top of our Facebook feed
this morning sadly pretty consistently
the answer to this question is violence
bigotry and fear just like I pay too
much attention to KY Centrum's
so do too we collectively pay too much
attention to the world's negative
behaviors it's not that we don't care
about the quiet act or the moments of
cooperation we're just not trained to
see them it's very unusual to see
stories of nonviolent resistance and
cooperation on the front pages of our
newspapers or trending on social media
the message we are collectively sending
it's clear if you need to grab our
attention use violence
day in and day out we have been turning
violence into a functional behavior and
non-violence into an ineffective
mechanism for addressing our problems I
want to propose to the class of 2017
that we have a shared responsibility an
urgent one to drive what the world pays
attention to never before have the words
of the Canadian philosopher Marshall
McLuhan been so true on Spaceship Earth
there are no passengers we are all crew
the content we choose to consume and pay
attention drives and determines where we
go and it's time we took responsibility
for it
right now too many of us are behaving as
passengers let's take a closer look at
what that looks like much of our lives
are spent online we read our news online
we watch movies online we are shopping
online we donate to causes online and
every single action we take is monitored
in detailed fashion and put into
algorithms that then determine what is
produced and sold back to us these
algorithms are used to determine what
stories we collectively tells about what
life on earth looks like today the
stories that set our agenda is a
community that determined what our
priorities should be the dynamic online
is the same that plays out offline but
on steroids in the solution in both of
these settings is for us to be conscious
about where we direct the most valuable
currency our modern world has our own
individual attention choosing where
replace our attention is one of the most
political acts one can take in the world
today the godfathers of non-violence
knew that well when Gandhi arrived in
India from South Africa he immediately
set up two newspapers he knew that in
order to get people to join his
nonviolent actions he would have to show
his community that actions such as the
salt march would attract public
attention and what a better way to do
that than to establish your own
newspapers the leaders of the civil
rights movement also knew the power of
attention as Martin Luther King put it
we have to dramatize nonviolent actions
so that the cause can no longer be
ignored many of the civil rights
activities such as the Montgomery bus
boycott led by Rosa Parks were carefully
planned to maximize media coverage
I have personally witnessed the dynamic
between public attention
and non-violence play out in one of the
most divisive conflicts in the world
today step between Israel and the
Palestinians when I was a student here
at Columbia I had promised myself I was
never going to get involved in very
early Palestinian conflict I felt like
there was way too much attention being
paid to it and all the rotation wasn't
really helping but when I arrived in
Jerusalem
to work on my first film something
struck me it was true that a lot of
attention was being paid to it but it
was the wrong kind of attention well the
media focused on violent actors or
failed political agreements the
Palestinian and Israeli civilians
working to end the occupation and the
conflict through classic civil
disobedience went unnoticed for example
how many of you are aware that hundreds
of Palestinian prisoners in Israel are
currently on an open-ended hunger strike
now in its 28 day seeking to improve
prison conditions the graduating class
of 2017 is doing pretty well but not
that many among us and I don't blame you
the media has consistently failed to
reinforce non-violence by ignoring acts
of civil disobedience when they happen
that's true in Palestine and elsewhere
that's why for the past 13 years working
with a nonprofit called just vision I've
dedicated my life trying to transform
this dynamic together with an
extraordinary team of Israelis
Palestinians and North Americans I have
researched documented and disseminated
the stories of hundreds of Israeli and
Palestinian civilians working to end the
conflict through nonviolent means most
recently we brought the stories of
nonviolent resistance emanating from a
Palestinian village in the west bank
called Buddhist and a neighborhood in
Jerusalem called Shahada
in a few months we'll be releasing a new
film which tells the story of four
Palestinian women who led a non-violent
uprising in the late 1980s that shape
the history of the conflict but who have
remained completely anonymous until now
the men and women we portray faced harsh
consequences for their activism but in
the future I am confident we will look
back at them with generation with today
reserved to Gandhi Martin Luther King
and Mandela there is a lot of work to do
before that time comes but the good news
is that we all carry in ourselves the
power to bring that forth by choosing
the way we look at the world we can
change it I am optimistic not because
the problems we're facing or small but
because I know that our ability to
overcome challenges is much greater than
we often give ourselves credit for so my
challenge to the graduating class of
2017 is this are we going to be
proactive in helping shape the world we
believe is possible or are we going to
be reactive in ceding the world we fear
whatever field you are about to enter be
the law anthropology Theatre medicine
film engineering astronomy I encourage
you to bring fresh eyes to your field
and to take the time to understand what
kinds of functional behaviors prior
generations of lawyers doctors actors or
engineers have been encouraging are
those good functional behaviors would we
be better off by nurturing other
dynamics this word takes discipline I've
learned this is a lifelong practice but
being mindful of where we pay attention
to can help us build a much more
cooperative beautiful and fulfilling
world
so as you walked out of here remind
yourself of the power that you all carry
inherently inside of you and the
responsibility that comes with it
where you turn your attention every day
has huge consequences to the world we
live in we can shape the dynamics of
Road conflicts ensure the best ideas
move forward and live happier more
meaningful lives by carefully choosing
where we turn the most valuable currency
of our times thank you
Thank You Julia in the first line of her
application essay our salutatorian
Roseanne Gooding Silverwood writes I
grew up in Texas land a blue skies and D
s mm-hmm so I guess one could say that I
was born and bred for fiction Roseanne a
child of the 60s and 70s sang in a band
and aspired to be a rock star she taught
and ran ashrams in California and New
York she met and married the man of her
dreams she wrote an award-winning
children's book and created an acclaimed
writing curriculum for elementary school
students while also raising three
children two of her three daughters are
Columbia graduates after taking a few
courses at Northern Virginia Community
College Roseann was hooked she decided
to follow in her daughter's footsteps
and apply to Columbia where she has had
a stellar academic career this past
April she was guest speaker at the
dynamic Women's Conference where she
presented the results of her claimed
senior thesis Roseanne's time at
Columbia has been transformative in many
ways which she will tell you about
herself
Roseanne Gooding Silverwood graduates
with better than in a average honors in
anthropology summa laude a Phi Beta
Kappa and as a member of the GS Honor
Society next year she will continue to
pursue her master's in oral history here
at Columbia a program that she began
this past summer
sir please join me in welcoming the
salutatorian of the class of 2017 and
force of nature roseanne Gooding
Silverwood
Oh
[Applause]
president Bollinger Provost cotesworth
Provost bowl executive vice president
Madigan vice president if our beloved
being on well fellow graduates families
maitake joke ma good morning yomijima
le MoMA cot ello y de ba Chi Chi
may we be together as one on the sacred
indigenous land of the lemei Linate
people
[Applause]
by the end of this fall semester I had
completed the requirements for
graduation but decided to stay on in
order to study the Chickasaw language
the mother tongue that my grandfathers
and grandmothers were forbidden to speak
in the missionary schools of Indian
Territory the reclamation of my family's
language and erased indigenous heritage
is one of the most precious gifts that I
take with me as I graduate I am indebted
to the professors and colleagues who
provided me with the history and
language that enabled me to hear what
the ghost haunting my family tree had to
say about the Unconquered and
unconquerable spirit of indigenous
peoples
I'm especially grateful to Professor
Audra Simpson always quick to admonish
me whenever I introduced myself as a
second class student what is it with you
geezers she'd say don't you know how
much professors love you she never let
me forget that I have something of value
to add to Columbia University the
Chickasaw Nation and the in Native
American community at large part of
learning the Chickasaw language entails
an elder giving you your Indian name
since my own Chickasaw father and
grandfather have passed away I asked my
eldest daughter to name me so hochi
fought
I'm Kang Bobby I choked Milito see I am
called tender Hawk because of a medicine
walk that I took last year in Riverside
Park and my encounter with a red-tailed
hawk who returned something to me that I
had lost before I came to GS something
that I hoped the school would help me to
recover for those who are unfamiliar a
medicine walk is an indigenous curing
ceremony that basically entails going
for a walk remaining alert for signs
that might offer guidance to a
particularly vexing problem whether it's
a relationship conflict or deciding on
an automobile purchase Indians have
always seemed to understood that the
science behind keeping one's feet moving
is in order for the brain to become more
receptive to insight my struggle had to
do with writing my senior thesis I had
hit a wall I could not write I could not
think I could not imagine
how I would ever find my way out of my
academic paralysis clearly I'm not the
first person student who have suffered
from writing blocked with a senior
thesis so I should give a little
background in order for you to
appreciate the weight of that literary
standstill I am a writer I have
considered myself a writer ever since I
was in the fifth grade and wrote a
poetry book for my mother entitled my
sullen childhood so naturally in the
personal essay that I had to write for
my application to GS I bragged about my
expertise the dozens of writing
workshops I'd attended my published
short stories and the award I had
received for a children's story I wrote
about the Chickasaws forced removal from
our homeland on the Trail of Tears I
also offered up my most meaningful
accomplishment the successful writing
program that I had developed and taught
that gave hundreds of Fairfax County
elementary school students the
experience of writing editing and
publishing school literary journals what
I failed to mention in that glowing
account of my literary talents was that
in the year preceding my application I
had stopped writing period nada kaput I
would sit at my desk and stare at the
blank page in a daze of self-loathing
plenty of writers will tell you that
there's no such thing as writer's block
with my own students I would share the
advice that children's book author Jane
Yolen offers for getting unstuck be I
see but in chair
but when I found myself in the thick of
parenting three teenage and young adult
daughters my writing world turned upside
down as my daughters were swept up into
the Firestone storm of bullying drug and
alcohol abuse eating disorders sexual
assaults and suicide attempts I found
out just how little control I had over
my life and my daughter's choices by the
time one of my twin daughters was
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder any fantasy that I had of an
intact family was shattered I became as
bereft and empty of daylight as Dimitar
when her daughter Persephone was
abducted to the underworld for Demeter
flowers no longer blossomed for me words
no longer held meaning and I stopped
writing any parent who has lived with a
child suffering from trauma or severe
mental illness knows that there are some
things from which a family never comes
back I cannot conceive that I will ever
be able to write my way out of the dark
days that came before or after the
diagnosis but apparently I wasn't ready
to give up on writing entirely because
when one of my daughter's got into
Columbia College and then mentioned that
she would not be averse to me applying
2gf I sat down and started writing that
personal essay like my life depended on
it in retrospect it probably did I had
always regretted dropping out of college
back in the early 70s so why not seize
that demon by the horns
if someone gave me a writing assignment
rather than my having to pull unicorns
out of my ears perhaps that might
jumpstart my creative juices I was
accepted into GS and although I was a
tad nervous on that first day of
university writing class I entered the
room thinking hey I was a writer once
I've got this but after taking one look
at the syllabus I was like what the hell
have I got myself into fortunately this
was one of the few classes where older G
s students are in the majority so I was
spared the humiliation of having younger
students witnessed my tears as I
discovered just how far in over my head
I was but as humiliated as I felt I did
not want my daughters to see me quit
from that moment on it was a furious
non-stop scramble not only did I have to
navigate the rigors within these Ivy
covered halls I was managing a
long-distance marriage stumbling on the
treacherous rim rocks of my daughter's
middle illness meanwhile jetting to
Texas twice a month to do crossword
puzzles with my mother who was sliding
deeper into dementia in the year before
she passed away what I saw my when I saw
my G s colleagues managing similarly
trying circumstances and moreover
holding down full-time jobs it was hard
to feel sorry for myself but here's the
weird thing with little time to think
about the devastation taking place in my
personal life the rigor and the pace of
my classes gave me relief
whether I was conjugating verbs for
Catalan or formatting footnotes for an
anthropology essay homework with Tish
holy tapa sacred medicine in fact had it
not been for the demands of this
institution
combined with the compassion of those
academic advisors professors and
classmates who knew of my family
situation I believe I would have jumped
off a cliff and somewhere along the way
I recovered my love of writing maybe it
was because I was so close to finishing
my degree that I could taste it but when
I saw that senior thesis looming on the
horizon I froze once again it was just
me the blank page and my self-loathing
that's why I took the medicine walk and
there I was heading back home still
feeling confused and doubtful about how
to proceed and just as I was about to
cross Riverside Drive I happened to look
up and there perched on the ledge of one
of the apartment buildings I spied a
couple of red-tailed hawks as soon as I
saw them one Hawk left off the ledge and
with wings tucked in a glorious free
fall as if I were some sort of delicious
prey she dove straight at me this weird
mix of terror and astonishment caused me
to let out a Yelp and suddenly in a
spectacle of Abyan grandstanding the
hawk opened her wings and swept right
over the top of my head and when I
turned around to see where she'd flown I
found her perched on a tree branch right
behind me she looked directly at me as
to say 'hey ho woman there is no good
reason why you should not be riding with
the same mastery that I fly I went home
and began to write with the fearless
intensity and I have to say I absolutely
crushed that thesis
a few weeks ago one of my favorite
professors Thomas Romo was talking in
class about overcoming creative blocks
saying look one day a baby bird doesn't
know how to fly the next it does and
after that it never forgets whether or
not I am able to sustain my confidence
outside the safe nest of this
institution remains to be seen
honestly I'm as tentative about my
future as any one of you here who like
me might not have that dream job lined
up after graduation I know my family
will continue to deal with the fallout
of trauma and mental illness but we are
learning to find tenderness with each
other and ourselves meanwhile my husband
has been counting the days until I
graduate so that we can spend an entire
weekend together without my having to do
homework certainly this honor of
salutatorian obligates me to keep
writing but more important I hope to
never again forget what it feels like to
fly
yamo musky
[Applause]
each year the Alumni key is awarded to a
senior who has achieved distinction both
academically and through service to the
undergraduate community this year the
Alumni key award will be presented by
our distinguished alumnus and co-chair
of the GS Alumni Association mr. Jesse
Dean Jessie graduated laude from G s
in 2008 with a major in sociology and
creative writing mr. Dean is director of
digital communications and marketing at
the Visiting Nurse Association Health
Group since his graduation jesse has
been one of the most loyal active and
committed members of the GS Alumni
community the 2017 Alumni key is awarded
to Aaron gov enter
[Applause]
aeryn aeryn has had an almost two
decades career as a professional dancer
as well as producer and designer of live
theatre and dance events across the
country at Columbia Miska Venters
completed a film major with honors while
also pursuing serious court coursework
and research in art history and cultural
anthropology one of her recent films has
been accepted by the Columbia University
film festival a true internationalist
aaron has during her time at Columbia
pursued seven different international
programs in places as diverse as Mexico
France and Japan Aaron's engagement with
the Columbia community has been nothing
short of amazing
her involvement range from orientation
to mental health the mid semester
success series military veterans student
council and many many other impactful
and transformational efforts Aaron's
legacy at yes in Columbia will be felt
for many years to come Aaron gov enter
graduates with honors in film summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa and as a member of
the GS Honor Society congratulations
Aris
thank you
we are particularly pleased this year to
present the second annual Campbell Award
the original announcement of the award
two years ago reads the University
trustees and the board of the Columbia
Alumni Association established the
Campbell award presented by the Columbia
Alumni Association to the graduating
senior at each school who shows
exceptional leadership and Columbia
Columbia Spirit exemplified by the late
Bill Campbell Columbia College class of
62 Teachers College class of 64 chair
emeritus of the board of trustees and
co-founder of the Columbia Alumni
Association the Campbell award will be
presented by mr. Justin Nathaniel Carter
gs-14 who came from California to be
with us today
Justin is a clinical researcher in the
department of radiation oncology at
Stanford Medical School he is currently
a member of the board of the Columbia
Alumni Association while an
undergraduate at GS justin held so many
important positions the list is too long
to read I will mention however that he
served as GS senator for two years and
was an incredible force for positive
change in the community while a student
Justin also amassed the largest
collection known to exist of genuinely
unflattering photos of me
[Laughter]
you won't have me to kick around anymore
the winner of this year's Campbell award
is mr. Franklin for
Franklin
Franklin is a native New Yorker and at
yes he majored in architecture Franklin
is a Beeson research fellow and Gilman
scholar at GS he served as an
orientation leader in junior Marshall
multiple times
Franklin is president and co-founder of
the student color Alliance a member of
the GS health and wellness coalition a
peer advisor a member of the
university's race ethnicity and
inclusion task force and senior class
president this this summer as part of a
Japanese government-sponsored program
Franklin will be teaching in Japan about
the influence of architecture in society
[Applause]
next year he will begin a master's
program in urban planning at the Kent
School of Architecture in Canterbury
England please join me in congratulating
our Campbell Award winner Franklin
the remaining academic prizes and awards
for leadership were presented at the
student leadership and academic prizes
dinner on May 2nd
please refer to your program for the
names of these extraordinary graduates
who represent in a compelling way the
Columbia tradition of academic
excellence and commitment to community
service good morning my name is Tom
Harford and I'm the dean of students in
the school of general studies president
Bollinger Provost cotesworth executive
vice president Madigan chaplain Davis
Provost wall vice president it Dean on
Ms bachi Dean Valentini mr. Dean
mr. Carter distinguished faculty
dedicated alumni assembled guests it is
my pleasure to present to you our
candidates for The Bachelor of Arts in
the school of general studies class of
2017 each degree candidate will receive
a certificate of achievement from
president Bollinger and we'll pause very
briefly to be photographed with Dean on
Jessie Dean G s class of 2008 will
present each graduate with a GS alumni
pin wear this pin with pride and let it
serve as a reminder of your academic
achievement and the time you spent at G
s now to the wonderful supportive and
vocal family and friends that have
gathered today I humbly ask that you
please hold your applause until the
graduates have been presented on the
stage we would not want to have one
family's excitement drown out the
presentation of another proud families
graduate I promise you there will be
plenty of opportunities for applause and
celebration when the presentation of the
class of 2017 is complete thank you so
much for your understanding and
restraint
with a few exceptions here and there
this year's class will be presented in
alphabetical order approximately well
the candidates for the degree of
Bachelor of Arts please step forward for
us Abdul Samad Bachelor of Arts Middle
Eastern South Asian and African Studies
Franklyn Forbes Bachelor of Arts
architecture
Erin Courtney Gavin tur bachelor arts
film and Media Studies departmental
honors Phi Beta Kappa Ellie Abbott tool
Bachelor of Arts Financial Economics
Ross William Adler Bachelor of Arts
sociology with a concentration in
history Laura Cabrera Bachelor of Arts
psychology Matan cinnamon bachelor of
arts philosophy concentration in
linguistics laude
Omri admin Bachelor of Arts economics
philosophy Jessica Aguilar Hernandez
Bachelor of Arts human rights
Theodore Wesley all filled Bachelor of
Arts computer science with a
concentration in mathematics
Joya ashen ahmad Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior laude Juan
David Alvarez Bachelor of Arts art
history laude Rosanna Gooding
Silverwood Bachelor of Arts anthropology
summa laude departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa Cowan burgess Valentini
Bachelor of Arts Applied Mathematics
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Spenser
John Allison Bachelor of Arts English
irma alia nari Bachelor of Arts
psychology departmental honors Phi Beta
Kappa idea Luke Bachelor of Arts
religion magna laude
Stevie Terrell Alston Bachelor of Arts
architecture Omron David Altman Bachelor
of Arts sociology magna laude
michael Alvarez Bachelor of Arts
economics Oscar Alvarez Bachelor of Arts
economics mathematics Phi Beta Kappa
Marielle Alvino Bachelor of Arts
financial economics magna laude
Robin Jacob Amiga Bachelor of Arts
economics garden absalom Bachelor of art
economics
Pierre Edward on - Keith Bachelor of
Arts political science statistics summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Jean Aviv Anton
Oh Bachelor of Arts political science
magna laude Donna Sarah
Ascari Bachelor of Arts history and
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies double major magna laude
Bradley Aslam Bachelor of Arts economics
laude rebecca a Celine Vera bachelor
hearts economics concentration in
American Studies summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Abdullatif Asimov Bachelor of
Arts financial economics Lucas James
Bell V Bachelor of Arts financial
economics
isogenic Banali Bachelor of Arts
ethnicity and race studies grandma
Canberra
Bachelor of Arts computer science
laude della Barboza Bachelor of Arts
psychology Charlotte Christine Barnett
Bachelor of Arts film and Media Studies
Anna barskaya Bachelor of Arts economics
concentration in art history Christopher
Michael Byers Schmidt by Bachelor of
Arts biological sciences gabriela ayelet
burnett Koonin Bachelor of Arts
sociology Jeannine Julia Baker Bachelor
of Arts religion magna laude davido
Danielle vegan special arts philosophy
laude Holly Lynn black Bachelor of
Arts visual arts
Elizabeth Wyatt Blackwell petrol heart
psychology magna laude departmental
honors
Alice Murray Manuel Blashaw Bachelor of
Arts political science concentration
business management
Charles Harry bloom sack Bachelor of
Arts computer science laude
Elliott Lock bowls bachelor of arts
philosophy laude Caroline cascada
Braga Bachelor of Arts political science
Noah Joseph brave Asheville varsity
laude the Kalani Elizabeth brown
Bachelor of Arts biological sciences
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Leslie Bruce Bachelor of Arts psychology
laude
Lydia Belle Bachelor of Arts religion
Charles Jared Buckley Metro Arts
mathematics statistics Jake Bullock
Bachelor of Arts computer science
laude lauren burns Coney Bachelor of
Arts philosophy and psychology double
major magna laude Thalia Yvonne
Burton Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude
Ricardo Alberto Bustamante Bachelor of
Arts music magna laude Graham Thomas
Karen special of Arts human rights
concentration East Asian Studies magna
laude Rosalee furlongs Yvonne Calvin
Sobyanin bachelor of arts history summa
laude a Phi Beta Kappa Lukas Vanya
Capra Bachelor of Arts political science
Rachel Michelle kuduro Matt Bachelor of
Arts psychology Alexander Chabot special
arts political science Shh on Bachelor
of Arts financial economics laude
Albert in Chang Bachelor of Arts
political science concentration in
English
chi-ching chi-ching might betcha betcha
love arts political science Ming - VJ
Bachelor of Arts psychology summa
laude sarah morgan Charles Batchelor
arts neurosciences and behavior
concentration in computer science
Gregory yuan Chen Bachelor of Arts
computer science magna laude
Zhang Haitian Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics Nicholas Albert Renee Chenault
Bachelor of Arts computer science
nikolaos Evita noise Bachelor of Arts
economics magna laude
soo-ji Troy Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior wrong night
Roy Bachelor of Arts economics Daniel H
Co Bachelor of Arts computer science
magna laude
Carlos James Costello Bachelor of Arts
film and Media Studies magna laude
Shane count Special Arts economics
laude robert Alva Kane
of arts urban studies summa laude
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa mark
Jared kutoro Bachelor of Arts sociology
with a concentration in visual arts
Gregory Vallarta quest Bachelor of Arts
information sciences John Leonard Davis
Bachelor of Arts French and francophone
studies Valerie and Olson Bachelor of
Arts computer science and mathematics
Melissa Padilla tendinous valve Arts
Financial Economics Daniel mark de saw
Bachelor of Arts political science a
Vika chime Dolan Bachelor of Arts
computer science Armando and towel
Dominguez Bachelor of Arts Earth
Sciences Dante le o.co Bachelor of Arts
chemistry summa laude departmental
honors Phi Beta Kappa Iago dos Santos
Bachelor of Arts political science
Lauren Danielle Kelly Oulu Bachelor of
Arts political science side Mohammad
dusky Bachelor of Arts economics Don
Ruth Doyle Bachelor of Arts English
Matthew Gardner Doyle bachelor arts
political science summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Charles Francois married to
passage Bachelor of Arts economics
political science summa laude megan
elizabeth edwards special hearts woman
and gender studies concentration in
english magna laude andrew robert
earl Bachelor of Arts history laude
Oliver Michael escargot Bachelor of Arts
political science lauren marie Fabiano
Bachelor of Arts sustainable development
Geezer odd taberu Bachelor of Arts
economics mohammad mustafa fall bachelor
of arts financial economics magna
laude shy pension Fong Bachelor of Arts
history Piron Fong Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics magna laude
statistics departmental honors Diego
folio Bachelor of Arts political science
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Valerie
Jean fan bachelor of arts history summa
laude departmental honors
Cecilia Marie Ferriero Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Nika Fleck Bachelor of Arts
anthropology laude
Catherine poem in Bachelor of Arts
computer science Kari Fox Bachelor of
Arts architecture
Jessica Olson Madeline Friedman Bachelor
of Arts ethnicity and race summa
laude departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa
one on gala bachelor of arts philosophy
visual arts laude Jennifer Garcia
Bachelor of Arts psychology jennifer
Jane garrison Bachelor of Arts English
concentration in Jazz Studies benjamin
scotch Godard Oh Bachelor of Arts
economics laude ryan glenn get free
Bachelor of Arts sociology or Rita
Hawtree Bachelor of Arts English and
comparative literature Conor Griffin
gets bachelor of arts history summa
laude
Brewed Rocco Pina Bachelor of Arts
computer science summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa sits long got Bachelor of
Arts psychology Matias Julian Gregory
Bachelor of Arts political science
concentration in business management
magna laude Elisha Zachary grant
Bachelor arts political science summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Myles lot
Grantham Bachelor of Arts political
science Madelyn grave Achille of Arts
visual arts Ari Solomon Greenberg
Bachelor of Arts yudish language and
literature
Daria Greene Oh Bachelor of Arts
economics Morgan Joan Davis special of
arts political science Corey Benjamin
her special arts political science magna
laude elizabeth Adam his special of
Arts economics Kurt Edward grunts key
Bachelor of Arts mathematics
Benjamin gully on bachelors economics
magna laude
etai hidari Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience and behavior Sharona levy
Bachelor of Arts Middle Eastern South
Asian and African Studies with a
concentration in Jewish Studies Jin Han
Bachelor of Arts political science Brian
Lee House Laur Bachelor of Arts
political science Clara Matilda hurlan
Bachelor of Arts financial economics
magna laude grace Ann Marie Harod
Bachelor of Arts psychology Nora Sarah
Herman Bachelor of Arts psychology
laude Barbara and Hickam Bachelor of
Arts sustainable development
Hwang Jung Bachelor of Arts political
science Jean Emma if her Jin Bachelor of
Arts political science concentration in
sociology magna laude
Michael Scott Hickey Bachelor of Arts
English and history double major Jake
Aaron Hill Bachelor of Arts Classical
Studies magna laude
Maria Karolina Hines Bachelor of Arts
human right
Corbin Arthur Heinz special arts East
Asian Studies laude Karolina Vanessa
Hodgson Bachelor of Arts Latin American
and Caribbean studies
Ariella Giotto whole Bachelor of Arts
Middle Eastern South Asian and African
Studies youth Beatriz Hollander Bachelor
of Arts Theatre Arts Stuart miles hick
Dixon hicken Bachelor of Arts East Asian
Studies magna laude departmental
honors Michael Wayne Hughes Bachelor of
Arts sociology concentration and
psychology Samuel Patrick Hughes
Bachelor of Arts history laude
Soyoung Joe Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics Anna Joe Bachelor of Arts
human rights Isabella
Alina Victoria Johansson Bachelor of
Arts physics Maya Louise hunt Bachelor
of Arts evolutionary biology of the
human species laude andrew joseph
hurt Bachelor of Arts philosophy with a
concentration in German literature magna
laude me John Wong Bachelor of Arts
computer science a meet Aulani Bachelor
of Arts Financial Economics Venus
Kershaw Bachelor of Arts economics
Rochelle Siobhan Juanita Jackson
Bachelor of Arts computer science
Muhammad Ali Jamal Bachelor Arts
political science
Heydar Jemal baba Bachelor of Arts
economics Corey out van der Freeman
Bachelor of Arts economics summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa young Jin Kim
Bachelor of Arts mathematics statistics
junghwan Kim Bachelor of Arts economics
laude Sylvie Jenson Bachelor of Arts
Human Rights
Anika Jelani Bachelor of Arts creative
writing business concentration summa
laude Joon Suk Jin Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics
laude Brian Adam Jones Bachelor of
Arts political science
Jenice Margaret Jo
Bachelor of Arts political science
laude jelena Jovic Anderson Bachelor of
Arts political science Taran King
Bachelor of Arts political science Aleve
Karachi I Bachelor of Arts human rights
magna laude
Braden Michael Harris Katzman Bachelor
of Arts computer science Brett Jordan
Krasner Bachelor of Arts political
science zone on picasa Kshatriya
Bachelor of Arts creative writing
Marwin was him co Adri Bachelor of Arts
economics philosophy laude Peter
James Kiernan Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude young sook Kim
Bachelor of Arts mathematics statistics
Taiwo cam Bachelor of Arts economic
statistics laude courtney Elizabeth
King Bachelor of Arts sociology summa
laude departmental honors Phi Beta
Kappa Nikolas Thurman Kirby Bachelor of
Arts sustainable development
Emily clothing Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude
Daniela Kogan Bachelor of Arts
psychology no Mezrich horns gold
bachelor of arts history summa laude
Phi Beta Kappa Lindsey ray Cortez WA
Baxter love arts Middle Eastern South
Asian American Studies summa laude
christopher Hannigan Bachelor of Arts
creative writing
Justin lien Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics yaadon crush it's key bachelor
of arts history magna laude
John Joseph Cossack Bachelor of Arts
neuroscience behavior laude matthew
brian co tech Bachelor of Arts
psychology Elsa Vita Coco Bachelor of
Arts chemistry Peter Andrew laughs
Yvette Rove arts computer sciences and
economics double major
Alexandra Chloe Lake Bachelor of Arts
English summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Brock lemon Bachelor of Arts English
Julia ever playing Bachelor of Arts
human rights young JV Bachelor of Arts
economics magna laude our Mons
Emanuel latreille Bachelor of Arts
political science laude departmental
honors
Valentine Mary Lynn a Bachelor of Arts
human rights business management
concentration laude rachel is our
bachelor of arts psychology summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa
Fernan pierre-joseph Lefevre Bachelor of
Arts political science laude kingly
Bachelor of Arts political science jiho
Aaron Lee Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics
Benjamin Jesse Pedro Bachelor of Arts
political science with a concentration
in human rights Elsa Maria Lee Bachelor
of Arts film and media and financial
economics double major Johansson McGuire
Lee Bachelor of Arts Middle Eastern
South Asian and African Studies magna
laude
Kim Jeong long Bachelor of Arts
statistics magna laude Andrew Lewis
Bachelor of Arts psychology with a
concentration in political science Zhang
Li Bachelor of Arts psychology William
lamb Bachelor of Arts Middle Eastern
South Asian and African Studies
Patrick Lim Bachelor of Arts financial
economics Jane Kristine Luca Bachelor of
Arts German literature and culture
history and a departmental honors
Xingu bachelor of arts philosophy
Shinran MA Bachelor of Arts Financial
Economics with a concentration in
mathematics
Austin lui Mantell Bachelor of Arts
creative writing summa laude
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa Kelsi
Christine Marquis Bachelor of Arts
environmental science magna laude
zachary Theodora Masek Bachelor of Arts
history
MJ matera Bachelor of Arts psychology
laude
Julius an amine in BA Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences justine e noises
Bachelor of Arts sociology James Joseph
McConnell Bachelor of Arts philosophy in
Andrew Micucci Bachelor of Arts double
major philosophy and political science
summa laude departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa Sarah Ashton McKenna Bachelor
of Arts political science Dakota Wayne
Meadows Bachelor of Arts financial
economics laude
Oliver William R and me Bachelor of Arts
political science a J add a meta
Bachelor of Arts computer science magna
laude
nidia Jasmine Melendez Bachelor of
special arts psychology Xavier and Ricky
Mendez special verts
political science concentration in
visual arts laude IC immerse a doe
Bachelor
Bart's creative writing Christina Maria
mihalis Xu Bachelor of Arts sustainable
development magna laude Tony D
Senatore Bachelor of Arts sociology
magna laude merit as I am in Del
Vecchio arts film and Media Studies
magna laude
Elias amine Murali Bachelor of Arts
financial economics concentration in
business summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
summer Blake masu Bachelor of Arts
political science Tonya Moe Bachelor of
Arts art history laude zachary
Moffat Bachelor of Arts computer science
and German length literature and
cultured society Veera Mullen bachelor
of arts history magna laude matthew
Hanlon moanin Bachelor of Arts economics
magna laude growl Louise Montano
Bachelor of Arts sustainable development
Michael William Morgan Bachelor of Arts
political science chase J Morgan
bachelor arts biochemistry magna
laude departmental honors Muhammad Musa
Abby Bachelor of Arts neuroscientist
behavior pre-medical concentration
laude man's Alma's Lobby Bachelor of
Arts physics for the concentration in
mathematics Colin Anthony Mueller
Bachelor of Arts political science summa
laude
Arnold Louise Mueller Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics Matt Fred Munoz and
Mendez Bachelor of Arts neuroscience is
the behavior Maryanne Moo stack Bachelor
of Arts sociology Rafael Ernesto Nazira
Bachelor of Arts political science david
matthew neer Bachelor of Arts economics
Michael Harrison Dyer Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude Colin
William Newman bachelors our
anthropology Ibrahim and young Bachelor
of Arts computer science
Andrew Douglas Nicholson Nicholas
Bachelor of Arts double major history
and political science
Eric Paul's Nicholas Bachelor of Arts
political science concentration Middle
Eastern South Asian African Studies
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Sara
Elizabeth Novak learner Bachelor of Arts
psychology summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa
Safiye Shamu and Bachelor of Arts
psychology magna laude jennifer
michelle nugent Bachelor of Arts neuro
sciences and behavior laude
Constance Geneva Nuttall Bachelor of
Arts film immediate studies departmental
honors summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Stephen Girard O'Connell bachelor
history
concentration sociology laude pema
UNK move Bachelor of Arts psychology
Andrew John O'Reilly Bachelor arts
computer science summa laude justin
james alton bachelor of arts history
laude Yong gwee Park Bachelor of Arts
mathematics laude instruct Park
Bachelor of Arts film and Media Studies
laude
sangguk park Bachelor of Arts sociology
young bin Park Bachelor of Arts
economics mathematics laude Scottie
Lynn Schaffer Bachelor of Arts
environmental biology amber Ruth Paul
and Bachelor of Arts creative writing
summa laude alexander fox person
Bachelor of Arts human rights robert
august Paquette Bachelor of Arts history
Kareem Pathan Bachelor of Arts financial
economics valaria PC Bachelor of Arts
human rights in psychology double major
laude
Cameron Robert Pope Bachelor of Arts
political science a nice caddy Porto
Bachelor of Arts human rights
concentration of Visual Arts magna
laude Andrew Peter proto bachelor arts
biological sciences courtney marie
pruden Bachelor of Arts Slavic Studies
John a patsak Bachelor of Arts political
science die young leave bachelor of arts
mathematics summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa Ryan win Winfield Ramsay Bachelor
of Arts psychology magna laude
maxime OC of esther rangel Bachelor of
Arts political science Shawn Morgan
Raymond Bachelor of Arts neuro sciences
and behavior ashley Patrice Reed
bachelor of arts architecture
departmental honors laude Huang woo
Park Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics laude
Arthur Davidson Arthur David Patterson
Bachelor of Arts English in political
science double major
Jeremy Julian Reeves Bachelor of Arts
art history and history double major
summa laude departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa
Stephanie Alexandra Renault Bachelor of
Arts economic political science
laude jonathan racino Bachelor of Arts
information sciences max Gabriel Reddick
Bachelor of Arts creative writing
laude
Sofia rematch levar sustainable
development magna laude departmental
honors Hayley Michelle rich Wilson
Bachelor of Arts economic environmental
sciences Yannick Roman Bachelor of Arts
Biological Sciences David Merrick rose
and Bachelor of Arts financial economics
laude kaitlyn see Russell Bachelor
of Arts sustainable development
Burton Jacob Sachs Bachelor of Arts
statistics
sokku Bachelor of Arts double major
economics mathematics laude
Matilda Rama Bachelor of Arts political
clients business concentration magna
laude
Hamza Saeed Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics
Daniel Salaam Bachelor of Arts economics
giuseppe salvia Bachelor of Arts Jo
neurosciences and behavior
Eugene Edward Sanchez Bachelor of Arts
visual arts Joseph Francis Sanchez
Bachelor of Arts political science
annamaria szilágyi Bachelor of Arts
economics philosophy magna laude
Lindsey Nicole sieminski Bachelor of
Arts computer science
Lucy Baker Schmitz Bachelor of Arts
double major in human rights and
political science laude Abaco and
Schwartz special of arts creative
writing magna laude
Ronnie Siegel Bachelor of Arts financial
economics Phi Beta Kappa Bryan Brandon
Sookie Bachelor of Arts sustainable
development Keith Edward Roberts
Bachelor of Arts economics philosophy
ki dong Co vet reverse psychology magna
laude Jeffrey James Theriot Bachelor
of Arts computer science laude who
jingshan Bachelor of Arts financial
economics summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Z - an Bachelor of Arts economics magna
laude V Sherman Bachelor of Arts
English summa laude stephen thomas
sure weird Bachelor of Arts economics
Andreia Valentina Seema's Bachelor of
Arts information sciences magna
laude
Rogerio Nogueira Simoes Bachelor of Arts
film and Media Studies Anastasio Soto or
chinko Bachelor of Arts art history
business concentration magna laude
julia francesca Sisto Bachelor of Arts
technology business concentration magna
laude alexander her Oki Sato
Bachelor of Arts computer science
Jason charkham Bachelor of Arts
political science Vivian Hsu Bachelor of
Arts economics Raphael Paul's spoken age
special of Earth's history summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa Emory so for
Bachelor of Arts computer science
Betty Sobel Bachelor of Arts Urban
Studies laude Mona song Bachelor of
Arts film immediate ease magna laude
young young song Bachelor of Arts
mathematics statistics he Betty Torres
Bachelor of Arts urban studies laude
Michael Anthony's fiatter Bachelor of
Arts sustainable development well
William Thomas streaked in junior
Bachelor of Arts through the science
justin strong Bachelor of Arts political
science
we chose Shin Bachelor of Arts
psychology jaywen Shin Bachelor of Arts
visual art Farhat Suva novel of arts
financial economics laude Jason Paul
Swan Bachelor of Arts Earth Sciences
Andrew James sweet Bachelor of Arts
psychology magna laude
Victoria Alejandra tahan Bachelor of
Arts sociology
Emily a hunter vaguer Bachelor of Arts
creative writing summa laude
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa
sang-bong cam Bachelor of Arts economic
statistics yeolgong Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences young MacLean
Bachelor of Arts mathematics statistics
Michael socha Bachelor of Arts double
major psychology and religion summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa
Robert Soto Bachelor of Arts political
science Rodolfo Belle Vidya Bachelor of
Arts political science
jaclyn vestnik Bachelor of Arts
philosophy Daniela Lisa Truglio Bachelor
of Arts English
gingy original toh Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics David John Thompson
Bachelor Arts Middle Eastern South Asian
and African Studies
laude Romain Thomas special verts
human rights summa laude
Oliver Cal you've a Bachelor of Arts
computer science near Ashanti D'Silva
Bachelor of Arts applied mathematics
Caitlyn Ruth Carey Bachelor of Arts
political science summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa 19 Kim Bachelor of Arts
double major architect architecture and
sustainable development you beam km
bachelor arts economics with a
concentration in history Caitlin Regina
walks Berger Bachelor of Arts Middle
Eastern South Asian African Studies
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa
Margaret Andrews Brill Voorhees special
of Arts political science summa
laude Emanuel Marcus fun Russell
Bachelor of Arts Human Rights Nina
Anna Cohn immense the Theodore Bachelor
of Arts African American Studies
departmental honors magna laude
how young Wang Bachelor of Arts
psychology Ying Zheng Bachelor of Arts
physics with departmental honors on
hella common Risa Rivas Baxter Bachelor
of Arts history in theory of
architecture
Jane Eliza Schwartz Bachelor of Arts
history and theory of architecture Wendy
way Bachelor of Arts sociology Gillian
Katharine Fitzgerald Petrov arts
political science Salah Abdullah bassier
Bachelor of Arts history Daniela DiSanto
quiz resna Bachelor of Arts political
science with departmental honors yi wang
Bachelor of Arts economics laude CAI
yuan wang Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics laude yang Feng yang
Bachelor of Arts psychology magna
laude
Lisa Naomi Wahlberg Bachelor of Arts
English laude sarah Bryn Whitmer
Bachelor of Arts political science
concentration East Asian Studies magna
laude Jaclyn and well and white
Bachelor of Arts sociology laude
Giselle Elizabeth Robledo Bachelor of
Arts compare deliver insurance Society
laude
Shang Lin Zhu Bachelor of Arts economics
and political science summa laude
how Yin Bachelor of Arts information
Sciences concentration in linguistics
laude
Jonathan Valdes Bachelor of Arts
Financial Economics laude
Tyrone wood Rudolph Wilkinson
some of our computer sciences with a
concentration in biological sciences
Caroline Elizabeth wheeler Bachelor of
Arts mathematics with a concentration in
philosophy James Michael worried
Bachelor of Arts economics political
science Zeff sbond Bachelor of Arts
history and theory of architecture a
sure James plotnick Petrov arts
political science magna laude Zhang
Wei Shen Bachelor of Arts financial
economics summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Dawn Marie well special of art
sustainable development Ori Elias Wiener
Lautner Bachelor of Arts psychology
magna laude Blair Vail Bachelor of
Arts neuroscience and behavior summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa departmental honors
Allison Claire Yamamoto Bachelor of Arts
political science business concentration
laude
Nathan Webber Bachelor of Arts physics
Paul Teitelbaum bachelor of arts history
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Jacob Alexander Bronstein Bachelor of
Arts economics concentration mathematics
summa laude departmental honors Phi
Beta Kappa Leif Naz shokera Bachelor of
Arts psychology concentration sociology
summa laude a Phi Beta Kappa
Travis Rae Williamson Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude
Samuel Ellison Whitley Bachelor of Arts
Urban Studies summa laude
departmental honors Phi Beta Kappa Hyo
jeong's Sophia woo Bachelor of Arts
philosophy Dileep Martin Vita Bachelor
of Arts computer science Adam Jiwan John
Bachelor of Arts psychology
Benjamin Matthew Thompson Bachelor of
Arts French and fake francophone studies
laude
Elina Kurosawa Bachelor of Arts
sustainable development Sahir Wahid
Bachelor of Arts political science
Winston Toki way Bachelor of Arts double
major history and political science
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
departmental honors
yuria technical Kushi Bachelor of Arts
political science concentration East
Asian Studies magna laude
Khalid Ishmael Bachelor of Arts
comparative literature and society
Danijela American College Bachelor of
Arts human rights concentration Middle
Eastern South Asian African Studies Colo
D Eden bachelor bachelor
arts creative writing Laura Christian
Walker Bachelor of Arts psychology
business concentration magna laude
Vincent tan Bachelor of Arts biological
sciences East Asian Studies
concentration Maria Martina Bachelor of
Arts political science summa laude
Phi Beta Kappa
[Applause]
all right so will the very very
amazingly awesome
class of 2017 please rise ladies and
gentlemen I am proud to present to you
the unique gifted scrappy savvy and
always inspiring class of 2017 70th
anniversary class
[Applause]
all right
please be seated our valedictorian this
year is Colin Burgess Valentini colin is
a native of New Jersey which we won't
hold against him and the son of Columbia
professor of chemistry and Dean of
Columbia College James Valentini colin
is a proud veteran of the United States
Marine Corps where he attained the rank
of Corporal he served in combat in
Afghanistan as the vehicle commander for
a mobile assault platoon we would have
to go back to the time of the post-world
War two GI bill to identify another
occasion on which a military veteran was
valedictorian Collins achievement is
indicative of the extraordinary talent
and accomplishments of the 102 United
States veterans graduating this week
Collin will describe to you himself his
path to the military and then to GS
where he has achieved the highest level
of academic excellence in the Department
of Mathematics in addition to his
extraordinary academic performance
Collin worked at the Columbia Daily
Spectator as a cartoonist and data
analyst where he focused on modeling
social and media data Collin Valentini
has been named to the Dean's List every
semester during his four years at
Columbia he graduates with far better
than an a-average
a degree in applied mathematics summa
laude a Phi Beta Kappa and as a
member of the GS Honor Society next year
Collin will be joining that other GS
downtown goldman sachs
where he where he will be working in
their credit risk analytics group please
join me in welcoming the valedictorian
of the 70 70th anniversary class of 2017
Colin Burgess Valentina
[Applause]
president president Bollinger Provost
cotesworth executive vice president
Madigan Provost ville vice president if
Dean on fellow graduates families and
friends it is truly an honor to be
standing here among so many gifted men
and women from such diverse backgrounds
it's your support inspiration and
motivation that helped me succeed and
stand before you today
you should be exceptionally proud of
your achievement especially given that
some of you have done so while also
being parents volunteers full or
part-time employees and even military
reservists for many of us this day has
been a long time coming for me this is a
moment that for most of my life I was
certain would never happen when I was 18
years old I had little understanding of
who I was
what motivated me or what I wanted to do
with my life but the one thing I knew
was that I needed more time to figure it
out
growing up I was crazy about cars so
after high school I decided to go to
vocational school to become a mechanic
while I was there a friend of mine told
me he was joining the Marine Corps the
Marine Corps I thought what the hell is
that out of curiosity I requested more
information online and a day later a
recruiter called me and like so many
before him he was a master of persuasion
and embellishment
but not as it turned out a liar even
though I left the recruiting station
feeling like the next Achilles I was
drawn to the adventures I would
inevitably have the Brotherhood I would
soon be a part of and the real
contribution I would make to this
country I decided to enlist but before
heading to boot camp I had to take a
series of tests to determine which
occupational specialties I qualified for
and found out that I qualified for all
of them
but after speaking with a Marine veteran
in my hometown his advice was do the
infantry or don't do it at all it didn't
take long for me to realize that I was
in fact not achilles there was no
romance about my deployment to
Afghanistan but perhaps I learned even
more important lessons about what it
means to be part of a team and care for
the Marine next to you more than you
care about yourself these lessons stayed
with me even as I transitioned out of
the military once out of the Marine
Corps however I was faced with the same
question what should I do next in the
Marine Corps I had learned to seek out
excellence and set challenging goals for
myself I also realized that no serious
advancement was possible without a
college degree so I took a deep breath
and applied to Columbia obviously being
out of an academic setting for over five
years
does little to prepare you for an Ivy
League education I learned as much as
any other service member about
discipline teamwork and perseverance but
had forgotten equally as much about high
school algebra geometry
and trigonometry I was forced to start
out at the very bottom of the totem pole
precalculus of course so elementary for
most traditional Columbia undergrads
that it necessitates a friendly
disclaimer columbia college students do
not receive any credit for this course
and must see their advising dean the
class was taught by a phenomenally
gifted young PhD student named Andre and
a good who now teaches at MIT I'm sure
many of you remember him because our
class was almost entirely gs students in
order to cover nearly four years of high
school math in 12 weeks we moved at a
pace just short of breakneck in the
beginning I felt totally lost and
couldn't decipher the pages of online
lecture notes for each class but his
course felt different from the other
classes I was taking even today as I
look back to the notes that Andre had
written i'm inescapably intrigued by the
depth of the course while some
instructors might have used the
rudimentary subject matter as an excuse
to plod through the basics of high
school math andre was determined that
the class d is challenging as any other
college class you would take i didn't
know it at the time but that course
would prove to be the most important and
influential class I would take here it
introduced me to math at a higher level
and at some point during the semester it
scratched the part of my brain which is
not content with knowing only that
something is true I felt inspired or
perhaps more accurately compelled to
investigate why these things are true
mathematics quickly became the most
profound field of learning I had ever
encountered I realized that I loved its
search for objective truth I loved how
it could
Phin ative li prove concepts so
counterintuitive that you would be left
with no other choice but to reevaluate
how you viewed the entire world around
you I loved that it was the language of
science and that learning to interpret
equations and not just solve them was
the first step to understanding how the
world behaves but perhaps most of all I
loved that even though I'm most
certainly not a brilliant person I could
do well in mathematics simply by seeking
to answer the question in my mind that
seemed to be ceaselessly recurring why
that precalculus course was the most
influential course I took because it
revealed to me the specific search for
truth that actually gave meaning to my
world every choice I've made over the
past 20 years had led me to that
semester what I learned in that class
went far beyond the scope of the
material covered in lectures I realized
that to answer the question Who am I I
had to ask the question what do I want
to know each of us here one way or
another has likely found the answer to
that question during our time at
Columbia and if you haven't you're
probably further along in that search
than before you came here for me I found
that mathematics provided the means to
search for fundamental truths that made
a difference in my life for you it may
be arts or English or biology or theatre
it could be a centuries-old academic
discipline or it could be the product of
the last few years it took me a long
time and through a very unconventional
path before I stumbled upon what made me
curious but it has been a guiding light
ever since so even though now after what
has become almost precisely a nine-year
personal
evolution I again find myself a bit
apprehensive and unsure about which path
is right I'm reassured however that so
long as I faithfully follow my curiosity
the rest will fall into place you will
undoubtedly face further challenges
wherever you may find yourselves but
having worked alongside many of you I
know that you are all capable of
achieving a tremendous amount even in
the face of seemingly insurmountable
obstacles today you've proved that today
you are Columbia graduates
congratulations
[Applause]
congratulations to the graduates your
family's loved ones and friends you
embody in a spectacular way the mission
and vision of GSN Columbia I hope you
will stay involved with your Columbia
family for many years to come
I invite you all to continue the
celebration at the class Day reception
to be held under the tents on Avery
Plaza as you exit there will be student
marshals ready to guide you through the
maze to the reception since we are all
headed to the same place I asked that
our guests remain seated and allow the
president's party to exit first then our
graduates will exit followed by families
and friends thank you will the
candidates please stand
[Applause]